just to add feminism feminism in my
opinion destabilizes women simple as
it's that straightforward and for me as
a woman a lot of feminists that i see
their points are not even about oh i am
is it off okay
so um
for me when i hear feminists speak
they're not actually speaking about
women's empowerment they're talking
about men so much that they're they're
not even on point with what they're
trying their message they think they're
trying to send
and for me that shows me that feminism
is is something that shouldn't be
even in society they don't even need to
exist
to be honest let's be real and they got
all the rights they need now it's
illegal to pay people less and all this
sort of thing so i was going to say as
well with like the pay okay to say with
the pay gap now there is no pay gap
there is literally no pay gap when you
look at the stats for what they are
looking at
and it's illegal to pay someone on a
sexual discrimination basis yeah it's
literally the current happiness yeah
and there's quotas too for specifically
to hire women like you guys in their
favor yeah yeah so i'm like i'm sorry if
you can't if you can't get a job
that's on you yeah that's on you
to the point of feminism for me feminism
destabilizes women it destabilizes them
in such a way where they are not able to
fulfill their own desires even the ones
in their feminine idea ideology they
can't they can't reach those pinnacles
because it's not even realistic
they focus so much on
men
that it's like do you like men or not i
have to ask feminists when i hear them
speak i'm like so do you like men
i don't think they do no no
but the ideology in itself is
counterintuitive to their their mission
yeah so looking at
a traditional wife
um and the feminist ideals that men are
you know basically useless so why is it
that everything that men do in a
traditional role as a provider you're
trying to do
it doesn't make sense well that's what
they say like women become the men they
want to marry yeah so
my point is they fail to do that even if
they try to do it they fail because
they're not designed to do that they
don't actually
know and i know someone's going to send
for me they don't have the faculties to
do so because they're a woman and
there's nothing wrong with that as a
woman you have
attributes that men do not have and when
you try to assign feminine attributes to
a man you emasculate him you destroy a
relationship as a feminist because let's
be real a lot of feminists have children
so how did you end up with a man
yeah your id your ideology
ideology outwardly is men are trash and
anything men can do i can do but you're
still in a family unit you still want
traditional um
traditional
provisions from a man in in your
relationship but you don't respect men
you want a traditional man where they're
not traditional women there's a lot of
fake feminists even cardi b she's a fake
feminist she's rapping about all this
stuff but really when you get home she's
actually cooking cleaning and doing what
the hell tells her to do that let's
she ain't traditional though no i'm
saying she's a fake feminist is what i
said yeah so she was talking about i
don't cook i don't clean and women power
boss [ __ ] this sort of language but
then she's at home mopping up and doing
whatever he says and taking him back if
he cheats and so forth right and the
same as like all my women are
independent bloody daddy beyonce it's
the same thing that was a sort of
feminist sort of song and i was to the
left hold up all this stuff in a box to
the left that song as well these sort of
man-bashing songs but when you check it
out they're not bashing their man
they're taking whatever he says and
doing it well and and that's the thing
modern women are side chicks and that's
that's the thing most feminists you know
they're side chicks because again if you
ask a hundred percent of women who they
want they want twenty percent of men you
want a guy that's over six foot that's
15 percent of guys you want a guy that
makes over 70k per year i don't know
that stat but
but i i think it's like 20 30 percent of
guys so on top of that you want them to
be attractive it's a smaller and smaller
and smaller percentage and the problem
is before women used to prioritize the
the character of a man over the way he
looked and and his providing skills but
then when the development of birth
control happened women had the option to
sleep with whoever
and then try as a mating strategy
they'll maybe get a kid from the first
guy that had the genes they wanted and
marry the second guy that had the
providing provision
so that's why you hear girls say oh i
need to have my whole face they want to
succeed because they yeah the like whole
face because you know they they wanted
to get
the the alpha guys out of there out of
their system but the problem is once
you've had too many alpha guys you can't
go back and you're never going to be
satisfied in your marriage you get an
alpha widow term and i said that six six
six is six four six pack and six figures
and they end up not being that guy and
as you say you have so many of these
chad guys the giga jack chad's or
whatever they call him on the net or a
masculine men that are out here getting
all the girls and then they end up being
alpha widows because when they ain't
gonna have a guy that can deal with them
like that guy dealt with them that's why
the women always go back here to the man
that beat it up the best unfortunately
that's like a known thing women talk
amongst each other about that guy he did
it like this and he's the man and this
and that and it's quite an important
factor to these so-called alpha widows
because if the next man
is not sufficient in that particular
area in terms of the you know
sex then they're gonna be suffering i
have a story on this i always say girls
always have that one x they can't get
over
and that you'll see a girl she's dating
the next guy right but she's thinking
about the last guy she's not over it
doesn't matter like you know that she
would go back at his beck and call so i
put this on my story because well
someone else did i shared it and this
girl
responds to me
and she says not always it took me 10
years to realize i was delusional i go
to her profile she's married with like
kids
and i'm like does your husband know
well that whole
thing
that whole mindset comes from low
self-esteem so a lot of sorry a lot of
women they lead with their sexuality but
they don't have the confidence
in themselves they don't have that
confidence so when they're pursuing but
say for example they see a guy he's
trash basically he he doesn't have money
he can give no no he's trash in the
sense that we can give his sex basically
he has no money he hasn't got legit
leadership skills another man in their
life down the line has leadership skills
he has a decent amount of money his sex
is um then they still go back to the the
broke guy because of the sex
alongside a lot of other women who might
be seeing that man um it's about low
self low self esteem as a woman
i think that when it comes to your
sexuality when you give it to when you
give that away to a man in a way that's
you say the whole phase
you're opening yourself up emotionally
you're opening yours you're feeling
you're spreading yourself so thinly that
you actually don't realize that you
don't know what you want you don't know
no i i don't think it's low self-esteem
i think it's if anything high
self-esteem it's girls batting out of
their league exactly yeah and so and so
that's that's what i think i think it's
girls typically when when they're
because guys will have sex with anything
so it'll be like a girl four five six
sleeping with an eight nine or ten right
maybe looks wise might be sex wise so so
she thinks she's on that level and then
she'll go to the next guy and leave him
and go back to the old guy yeah but
that's what i'm saying so to me that
comes across as low self-esteem because
really her her whole thing the premise
of her whole position is based on that
man's looks alone whereas if you're
dealing with a real
man in my opinion not not always a man
that has faculties about him financially
stable he's solvent et cetera et cetera
but it's not related to the man it's
related to herself she's like i'm so
good i can get a chance she thinks i can
get a chat i can get a six
no woman is leaving if she doesn't think
she could do better exactly like i had a
girl it's about her self-esteem
i mean when you say that about everyone
yeah yeah yeah i agree but women are the
one leaving
yeah so it's like
a man sleeps with them because it's easy
sex basically because say he's deemed as
a eight or a nine or a ten and then a
five or six is like she fancies the hell
out of this guy she's letting it off
relatively freely because i said that
carnal urge is ridiculous he beats it up
and deals with it appropriately as he
should and then when he's like you're
just a five or six year later she goes
back to her boyfriend and finds another
guy on her level but she's always
craving for that guy and believes she's
capable of obtaining that type of man
but really all she was was an easy easy
beat
because because when men women face
don't face reality men do because every
bad choice women always coddle each
other so for example we have body
positivity
instead instead of saying lose weight
get on the treadmill if you want that
guy that's offensive like that's not
offensive no i know but that's in
i agree i don't think it's actually
offensive but in this society it is
body shaming and they call it wrong or
or there's like there's beauty stan like
unrealistic beauty standards it's like
no it's not unrealistic you just don't
fit it no but i don't think there's
anything wrong with having a beauty
standard every i mean there's an ideal
right why what's nothing wrong with that
i think
i think they've just created a a society
that just kind of panders we could we
could have lizzo go on a public platform
shooter shout out shooter shot at chris
hemsworth
and and everyone will cheer her on you
go girl you go sis and if a guy did that
if a fat short broke i did that with a
victoria's secret super bottle everyone
would be like laughing at it
yeah but that's what i'm saying like
women don't face reality men men do and
so that's why women are much more
delusional than men
yeah they're not but i feel required to
and that's the uh yeah that's the key
thing we're not required to uh political
correctness one mad
aspect favors women's delusions and the
problem with that is we don't not all
the women in this room but we don't
realize that we're depleting depleting
ourselves by doing that we're depleting
our
qualities and depleting our position by
doing that
um
i don't think there's anything wrong
with having an ideal i don't think
there's anything wrong with portraying
you know women as you know slim and b
there's nothing wrong with that i think
it only becomes uh it's i think society
has just made it an issue as if to say
oh no you have to be um if if you don't
like this woman who is like i don't know
600 pounds and then you're not being
fair and it's like well i'm not trying
to be funny but part of sexuality is you
have to discriminate you have to have a
type otherwise you're just sleeping with
anyone
yes or no it's part of the game exactly
but you don't accept it in this society
and you will get called out for being a
misogynist a fat shamer or if people
don't like particular races she'd be
called a colorist it could be called
anything to shame a man's preferences
but a woman can come out here like lizzo
and say he's got a short dick or small
dick no no one will say anything the
misandry they could be heightest and say
he's if he's not over this high i'm not
going to deal with him and they can even
shame your income so if you're incoming
to that level i don't want no scrubs
so these things is like it's not equal
in that terms of the game what if a guy
said i don't want no whales well
they went
they were i'm so sad it would be a
completely different
a completely different reaction
[Laughter]
if she's over 50 over 250 leave her ass
and then but they'll have rap lyrics
about if he's broke leave him yeah
double standard